a secret recording of President Trump
made by his former personal lawyer
appears to undercut the president's
denial of payments to a former Playboy
model Michael Cohen taped a conversation
with the president about a payment to a
woman a few months before the 2016
election
the woman had claimed that she had an
affair with mr. Trump
Errol Barnett is traveling with the
president in New Jersey
Errol good morning good morning
president Trump's personal attorney is
quoted as saying mr. Trump will not be
hurt by what is heard on this tape but
the White House itself has not responded
to reports that the president's former
personal attorney recorded private
conversations and possibly has others
with the commander-in-chief
landing in New Jersey for the weekend
President Trump ignored shouted
questions about the newly disclosed
recording with his former lawyer Michael
Cohen their conversation centers around
payments to this woman former Playboy
model Karen McDougal
who claims to have had an affair with
mr. Trump back in 2006 the roughly 2
minute recording held two months before
the 2016 presidential election was
uncovered by investigators in April
during raids on Cohen's home and offices
as part of a federal probe into his
business dealings that investigation is
examining Cohen's role in paying women
to stay silent about their alleged
affairs with mr. Trump before the
election if payments were made to help
get Trump elected they may violate
federal campaign finance laws the white
house repeatedly denies any knowledge of
a payment or any affair but mr. Trump's
lawyer Rudy Giuliani told the New York
Times Friday that the president did
participate in the secretly recorded
phone call about MacDougal months before
the election McDougall says the
publisher of the National Enquirer
purchased her story but never published
it commonly referred to as catch and
kill earlier this year she shared her
story with CNN you're convinced now this
was an effort to do a favor for Donald
Trump in the last few months of the
presidential race
unfortunately yes the only comment from
the White House so far comes from First
Lady Melania Trump spokeswoman who said
quote mrs. Trump remains focused on her
role as a mother and as first lady of
the United States now Rudy Giuliani also
told the New York Times that then
candidate Trump on this tape is proven
to have not been aware of the payments
to mcdougal at the beginning of the
conversation therefore it proves he did
nothing wrong
well Michael Cohen's lawyer Lanny Davis
responded by saying quote when the
recording is heard it will not hurt mr.
Cohen he went on to say that any attempt
at spin can not change what's on the
tape Anthony Errol Barnett with the
president in New Jersey thanks Errol